my name is Oliver touch panel from
Austria and I have a question for you do
you think that on the LHC start there is
the possibility that there come a little
black pole hi Oliver so you'd like to
know if there is a possibility of a
black hole being created from the Large
Hadron Collider the LHC so far we think
not the reason we think not is that
nature has already done this experiment
there are natural accelerators out there
in space that are far more powerful than
anything we can build here on earth or
even imagine every building here on
earth and so the experiment has been
done already by nature and so if there
are black holes being made and they're
small and they don't bother anyone but
more likely there are no such black
holes being made by those particle
collisions now of course we would
certainly be very interested to find out
if there were but we're not expecting
any